hey freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung ihr habt
gestern die 2500 likes mal wieder
gecrasht den seit mittlerweile schon bei
dem ganzen videos bei 9000 8000 7000
7000 likes das ist echt unnormal und da
jeder wirklich so abgeht und ich jetzt
auf zurzeit erst mal wieder schule habe
würde ich sagen dass das ganze erstmal
ab breche das war nämlich alles erst mal
nur ein test ob das ganze überhaupt
funktioniert ob er wirklich so viel bock
an den zieht vorstellungen habe das hat
wirklich funktioniert dafür möchte ich
mich erst mal bedanken es gibt natürlich
immer so ein paar leute dann mit den
argumenten kommt dass sich also der
bereich reise das ist auch einer der
gründe warum ich dass ich es mal ab
breche das war halt alles nur ein
kleines experiment ob ihr wirklich sehr
viel davon haben wollte und was sie
dafür ausgeben würde das also dass ihr
halt quali selbst bestimmen dürfte ob
wir jetzt eine neue sieht verstellung
wollt oder nicht ich kann auch gar keine
facebook machen ob meine kameras
komplett voll mit den ganzen teheran
zweifel games sachen die werden heute
noch hoch geladen bzw
morgen übermorgen ich habe auf jeden
fall richtig viel aufgenommen ich habe
auch im cpi cee holding aufgenommen
alles mit face kam alles am start kommt
als diese woche noch online könnt ihr
euch auf richtig was freuen
ich hab jetzt allerdings wieder schule
ich werde das jetzt einfach in zukunft
so regeln dass ich zu viele sieht
vorstellungen machen möchte wie nur eben
möglich weil ich durch diese app jetzt
auch die mehr freiheiten haben also ich
finde vieles sieht die ich für
angebracht halte dass sie quasi so hoch
sind quasi von der qualität her dass man
die auch in den video packen kann zwar
immer noch so ein paar sieht man findet
jetzt keine unglaublichen sieg hat
natürlich schon richtig geiles damals
mal vorgestellt aber ich möchte es noch
gar nicht so lang grün drum rum
quatschen also ich kann das ganze nicht
durchhalten hintermänner zu stellen das
tut mir sehr leid ich habe es probiert
er hat jetzt auf 50 vorstellungen direkt
untereinander erschwert dass in zukunft
wieder so machen dass ich mir nur so ein
bisschen immer so wenn ich pokere werde
ich das dann machen und dann werdet das
schon gesehen also name könnt ihr
einfach ja egal das ist derzeit 538 29
12 26 81 35 27 82 72 steht auch unten
immer in der beschreibung sowie erklären
uns die neue band allerdings selbst noch
nicht im vorstand haben morgen kommt
keineswegs verstellung vielleicht
übermorgen oder in drei tagen oder in
einer woche wenn ich halt wieder bock
drauf ab bzw wenn ich derzeit daran habt
dann werde ich so viele machen wie es
eben geht
so wie wir
wir befinden uns hier in einem stadium
das sieht alles nicht sooo geil aus das
einzig spektakuläre hier ist das da
hinten da sind ganz viele höhlen unter
dem eis allerdings wenn wir hier runter
gehen sehen wir hier schon eine höhle
und töten nur ganz kurz ein fackelte wir
haben ein doppelt sporer seit der 1.5
punkt eins ist es der fall dass es keine
doppelspur mehr gibt sondern das ist nur
dieses bonner hier gibt und wenn dann
zwei drin ist das einfach eine koppel
stone also der ist dann quasi weg
allerdings haben wir in diesen ganzen
kisten so viele geile sachen drin zeigt
euch das mal ganz kurz
wir haben nämlich ja in goldenen apfel
und die chancen goldenen apfel zu finden
ist glaube ich 0 1% oder irgendwie sowas
ist es richtig richtig krass wir haben
auf jeden fall sachen drin wie web nicht
dass ich die werke wieder aufnehme
empfindet die einst als ich mal kurz auf
deutsch dann könnt ihr das auch besser
verstehen so deutsch
wir haben hier zum beispiel dornen 1
unendlichkeit 1 explosionsschutz 1 und
unendlichkeit noch mal eins also das ist
richtig geil von schon mal von der
verzauberung herde haben werden so ganz
normale sachen wie schwarzpulver
kakaobohnen brot 15 fäden zwei redstone
sattel music des kw 335 weizen und dann
natürlich auch noch zehn eisenbahn auch
mal ganz gut vonstatten goldenen apfel
und das ein richtig geiler goldenen
apfel zu finden das ist schon sehr sehr
schwierig beziehungsweise sehr schwierig
den aufzug kraft nicht ob man muss gold
blöcke um den apfel rum tun oder irgend
sowas ist auf jeden fall eine ganz ganz
komplizierte sache beziehen magath
prozess um das hinzukriegen
und wie schon gesagt wir haben dann halt
die unter den eisplatten dass mich ein
auch immer mal so ab und an ein paar
höhlen einfach da könnt ihr euch auch so
ein bisschen durchschnitt also wirklich
alles unter dem eis sieht schon sehr
geil aus also ich habe wirklich eine
menge höhen einfach unter meisters sieht
schon krass geil aus einfach nur studium
ist jetzt nicht so dass alle geil finde
ich allerdings ganz cool dass jeder
direkt wirklich neben den doppelten
sporer seid ihr könnt dann zwar nur
einem opfer machen aber auf jeden fall
eine richtig geile direkt am sport
richtig geil einfach direkt am sport
hinbauen man muss nicht lang laufen man
hat sofort und sport das ist schon eine
coole sache
na ja ich würde einfach sagen es euch
gefallen dann würde ich mich über einen
daumen hoch freuen die nächste
vorstellung kommt den nächsten tagen
beziehungsweise wochen immer wir nicht
bock hab ich glaub schon drei vier tagen
oder so kommt man wieder eine aber ich
möchte nichts versprechen
es komme auf jeden fall noch eine menge
andere videos und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal dann
auch wieder mit festivals wahrscheinlich
euro